okay um
next game of this ice wide shot from
this denmark denmark french defense
i play the form
let's see what we get the classical
variation
yeah i think a3 is
the move they mostly play nowadays but
um
i don't really know this really
really in detail
this one maybe
uh-huh interesting
interesting yeah okay
yeah i need to take
very interesting maneuver from black to
get some play against the um the queen
side
maybe the b pawn
i didn't know this idea
well i don't know the line really so um
it's no big surprise that he played
something that
i never saw before i tried to prac
i tried to play knight d4 okay it
doesn't exchange
i thought in case of him exchanging i
can
recapture with the bishop cover b2 but
he played
maybe not c4 to come
the only objection here is that it all
takes
some time what is what it's doing here
can i somehow
profit okay this one is hanging but
i could play f5 to open up the position
immediately
this is an idea
let's try this
it takes on uf5 i think i take with the
knight
oh then i'm not sure i think okay
it just uh ignores this basically
but what um what is this if you play f6
what is what is he doing then g takes
check on g3 king h8 takes f6 and then v8
is hanging
don't i win the rook there or something
i could also if i take if i take now
you will have bishop d's and you'll know
that i have a queen h
form not sure
is this important let's take
take there immediately
and then the check really should pick up
the rook
unless he's got some brilliant trick
there
night air with on h4 or something
i don't think so
e5 he could play
black resigns no just resigned
yeah i don't think he's got any serious
compensation
if he takes queen h4 i've got bishop f2
now there shouldn't be anything just
quickly
yeah a computer gets plus six or plus
five or something
so there's no trick yeah
i'm not sure f5 maybe he needed to uh
he needed to think a little bit more
there
but longer which maybe you can really
take on f5 or maybe take on b2 it's um
of course um all a bit risky but
i didn't don't think he had much choice
there
castling i think because f6 just didn't
work
so nice quick win